we have a bit of a positive story for
you right now that has emerged from the
covid19 pandemic
and that story has to do with las vegas
entertainers denise
yeah throughout the past few months the
community has come together to spread
joy and hope
arko mana shows us what a group of local
singers did tonight
just in time for the holidays
planning a special surprise with the
classic christmas carol
this group of las vegas performers warm
up their voices in an effort to warm
some hearts
these entertainers really matter they
secure their santa hats do temperature
checks and grab some candles
dashing through the streets of this
northwest valley neighborhood
they placed microphones six feet apart
now the stage is set
[Music]
their performance of white christmas a
surprise birthday gift for beloved music
director and producer bill fein
bill fighting back tears i've never
felt so loved and cared for
like many in the las vegas entertainment
industry bill is struggling because of
the covet 19 pandemic one day you're
you're you're as depressed as can be
yes everything is gone and then the next
day you wake up and say okay
you gotta stay positive and seeing this
encourages him to keep fighting
it's just the most wonderful thing local
singer michelle johnson
organized this sweet surprise and says
now more than ever
entertainers like bill need support
you'd have to do a christmas carol
in the street for them but pick up the
phone and call them and check on them
because we have
all we have is each other a simple song
to make things more merry
and bright it gives me more hope for
the end of of this crazy year and the
beginning of something new
[Music]
orco mana 8 news now